हेलो गाइ वेलकम टू आवर
youtube0 का डे 13 तो आपको ऑलरेडी पता है
कि डे 12 तक जो है लेक्चर अपलोड कर दिए गए
हैं ठीक है आप यहां पर वीडियो सेक्शन में
आके देख सकते हैं हमारे
ठीक है चलिए आज हम लो करने वाले हैं डे 13
तो डे 13 में क्या होगा और हमने पहले कहां
तक किया था मैं आपको बता देता हूं सबसे
पहले उमीद करता हूं कि आपने पहले सारे
लेक्चर कंप्लीट कर लिए आप डायरेक्टली इस
लेक्चर पर जंप नहीं कर रहे हैं ठीक है
अपलाइन से चलिए एक लेक्चर को करते हुए
चलिए य पर मैं आ जाता हूं अपने य पर ट्रा
में ठीक है ा अगर आप लर्न प आते हैं लर्न
पर यहां पर मैं ओपन करता हूं आपके सामने
वापस से लर्न पर यहां पर आप मॉड्यूल में
आएंगे तो आपको यहां पर नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
का मॉड्यूल मिलेगा इसको हम लोग कर रहे थे
इसमें आ जाते
हैं अब यहां पर देख सकते हैं बहुत सार रूम
ऑलरेडी है जो कि हमने कर लिए थे कितने
हमने कर लिए थे हमने यहां कर लिया था ठीक
है य प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड सर्वर वाला जो रूम
है हमने यहां तक कंप्लीट कर लिया था इसके
बाद हमने दो रूम और किए थे नेटसेक चैलेंज
वन और टू करके ठीक है जो सर्च प था जो इस
मॉड्यूल का हिस्सा नहीं है पर मुझे लगा
जरूरी है तो मैंने वो भी करवाए थे ठीक है
चलिए तो हम लोग आगे करने वाले हैं यहां पर
मेरे में टिक नहीं लगा उसको इनोर करिएगा
अभी के लिए ठीक है लेकिन यहां पर हम लोग
कौन सा करेंगे आज प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड सर्वर
टू वाला इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं
मैं अब यहां पर य भी पेड है ठीक है मतलब
ये वाला जो रूम है वो भी पेड है तो आप
नहीं कर सकते तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आप
साथ में फॉलो कीजिए समझिए और नोट्स बनाते
चलिए ठीक है और चीजों को एनालाइज करने की
कोशिश कीजिए मतलब मैं कोई क्वेश्चन पूछता
हूं आप सोचिए कि क्या हो सकता है उसका
आंसर रोकिए सोचिए फिर कंटिन्यू करिए ठीक
है क्याक अप हो सकते हैं क्याक हो सकते है
कुछ नया आपने मेथोड सीखा उसको नोट करते
चलिए चलिए और फिर एक चीज मैं आपको और बता
दूं कि यहां पर हमारा लिंकन पेज भी है आप
उसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं जितने भी कुछ भी
लेटेस्ट न्यूज या कोई भी चीजें होंगी या
फिर कुछ आपके लिए एक्साइटिंग चीजें होंगी
या कुछ चैलेंस होंगे तो वो भी आपको यहां
पर मिल जाएंगे तो इसको जरूर से फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा और हमारा आप एड एप्लीकेशन भी
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं आपको जो डिस्काउंट
होते हैं लेटेस्ट डिस्काउंट आपको वहीं पर
मिलेंगे चलिए मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं
अभी के
लिए आ जाते हैं अपने हमलोग प्रोटोकॉल एंड
सर्वर टू वाले रूम प हमने यहां पर ऑलरेडी
अपना वेब बेस्ड काली ओपन कर लिया
है यहां पर मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर देता हूं
फिर हम लोग पढ़ते हैं यहां
पर ये चालू हो रहा है मैं आपको यहां पर
इंट्रोडक्शन देता हूं और हम लोग आगे बढ़ते
हैं तो हमने अभी तक क्या देखा था हमने यह
देखा था कि किस तरीके से हम अगर एक
नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट जाते हैं तो उसके बाद
से हमें कुछ यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं दी
गई है हम सिंपल एक नेटवर्क में कनेक्टेड
हैं ठीक है हमने समझा पहले कि नेटवर्क का
आर्किटेक्चर क्या है हम वो समझे पहले इस
टाइप का नेटवर्क है ठीक है वो समझने के
बाद उसपे कितने होस्ट कनेक्टेड है कितने
होस्ट लाइव है क्या चीजें हैं उनके बारे
में हम खुद से एन्यूमरेशन करें वो हमने
सीखा ठीक है वो करने के बाद जब हमें सारे
डिवाइस मिल जाए कि कितने डिवाइस हमारे पास
हैं अब वो हर एक डिवाइस में क्या-क्या
सर्विस चल रही है क्या-क्या हिडन सर्विस
चल रही है अगर उनमें से किसी पे फायरवॉल
है तो उसको बायपास कैसे करना है ये चीजें
हमने सीखी ठीक है हमने सर्विस का
एन्यूमरेशन किया फिर हमने उनमें जो
सर्विसेस रन हो रही होती है ठीक है उन
सर्विसेस में क्या-क्या कमी हो सकती है
हमने वो समझा उनमें क्या मिस कंफीग्रशन हो
सकते हैं क्योंकि वल्नरेबल तो चलो अपडेट
हो गया है कोई सर्विस आपका रन हो रहा तो
उसमें तो रहेगी ठीक है लेकिन मिस कॉन्फिन
एक बड़ी प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है ठीक है
क्योंकि जो लेटेस्ट सर्विसेस भी होती हैं
उसमें भी मिसकंफीग्रेशन
है या फिर उससे भी एक मैं आपको अच्छा मिस
कंफीग्रशन बताऊं तो वो है इजी पासवर्ड
रखना गेसेबल पासवर्ड रखना जो कि हमें लगता
नहीं है कि एक मिसकंफीग्रेशन है कि यार
हमारे पर अटैक कौन ही कर रहा है हमारे
सिस्टम पे कौन ही अटैक कर रहा है लेकिन वो
एक बहुत बड़ी जो है गलती साबित हो सकती है
तो इस टाइप के मिसक फिगरेशन जो होते हैं
वह दिक्कत कर सकते हैं हमें ठीक है चलिए
और कुछ ऐसे प्रोटोकॉल्स भी होते हैं जो कि
थोड़े मतलब अनसुने होते हैं कम लोगों ने
सुने होते हैं या उसपे कम लोग काम किए
होते हैं तो उसपे जब कोई बंदा सेट कर रहा
होता है कोई चीज तो उसमें ज्यादा मिसक
फिगरेशन का ध्यान नहीं रखता है क्योंकि वो
ब ज्यादा नोन प्रोटोकॉल्स नहीं है ठीक है
या फिर जब पन टेस्टर टेस्ट कर रहा होता है
तो उन प्रोटोकॉल्स प नहीं जाता है जैसे
हमने लास्ट क्लास में मेरे ख्याल से लास्ट
क्लास में हमने बात की थी रूट्स कशिंग की
ठीक है चलिए एनस प्रोटोकॉल से तो आपको याद
होगा वो चीज तो फिलहाल हम लोग यहां पर
क्या पढ़ पढ़ने वाले हैं अभी तक हमने इतनी
चीजें पढ़ ली है ठीक है अब हम ये पढ़ने
वाले हैं कि जिससे लास्ट जो हमने रूम देखे
थे दो रूम से पहले ठीक है ये वाला जो रूम
हमने देखा था प्रोटोकॉल सर्वर वाला और
लास्ट रूम जो थे वो भी इससे रिलेटेड थे तो
इन रूम में हमने कुछ इन प्रोटोकॉल्स की
बात की थी ठीक है और कुछ और प्रोटोकॉल्स
की भी बात की थी मेरे ख्याल से तो इन
प्रोटोकॉल्स जो हमने बात की थी ये सब
हमारे क्या हैं क्लियर टेक्स्ट प्रोटोकॉल
है ध्यान रखिएगा यहां पे एएच नहीं है ठीक
है तो यहां पर अब क्या बात होने वाली है
इस रूम में हम बात करने वाले हैं कि इन पे
किस-किस टाइप के पॉसिबल अटैक्स होते हैं
ठीक है ये मतलब क्लियर टेक्स्ट प्रोटोकॉल
के बेस पे ये नहीं कि ये इनमें से कोई
स्पेसिफिक नहीं रहेगा इन पे कहने का मतलब
ये है कि जो क्लियर टेक्स्ट प्रोटोकॉल है
उन पे किस किस टाइप की दिक्कतें आ सकती है
हम आज थोड़ा सा थ्योरी प जाएंगे पहले और
फिर हम एक चैलेंज सॉल्व करेंगे जो फाइनल
है इस रूम का चलिए इस मॉड्यूल का फला शुरू
करते हैं यहां पर तो यहां पर कुछ चार
चीजों के बारे में दिया हुआ है अब इन चार
चीजों का मतलब क्या है पहला है स्निफिंग
अटैक ठीक है इसमें क्या होता है कि इसमें
आप और आप जिस मतलब सर्वर से इंटरेक्ट कर
रहे हैं जैसे अगर आप कोई वेबसाइट व्यू कर
रहे हैं एचटीटीपीएस है एटीटीपी है कोई
वेबसाइट है ठीक है अगर वो प्लेन टेक्स्ट
में कम्युनिकेशन कर रही है क्लिय टेक्स्ट
में कम्युनिकेशन कर रही है तो बीच में अगर
कोई बंदा आके के ट्रैफिक को सुन पाता है
अगर तो वो आपका किस में आ जाएगा स्निफिंग
अटैक में ठीक है अभी उसे सुन पा रहा है अब
मैं इसको आपको डिटेल में समझाऊ ा चिंता
नहीं करनी है आप लोग को अभी ठीक है अभी बस
एक ऊपर ऊपर समझ लीजिए पहले इसको मैन इन द
मिडल अटैक ये क्या होता है अगर वो बंदा
बीच में आके उसको चेंज कर सकता है तो वो
मैन इन द मिडल अटैक में आ जाएगा इसके
अलावा पासवर्ड अटैक बड फोर्स टाइप की
चीजें ठीक है और वल्नरेबल तो आपको पता ही
है कि कोई अगर कमी ही है डायरेक्ट वर्जन
एक्सप्लोइटर या ऐसा कुछ दिक्कत है तो
वल्नरेबल में आ जाएगा चलिए तो पहले बात कर
लेते हैं आपको सीआईए ट्राट के बारे में तो
पता ही होगा लेकिन मैं आपको एक क्विक
रिवीजन करा देता हूं जल्दी से सीआई ट्राइड
मतलब आप किसी डाटा की जो है सिक्योरिटी को
डिफाइन कैसे कर रहे हैं ये आप कह सकते हैं
ये एक फ्रेमवर्क टाइप इसको कह सकते हैं ये
ट्रायड यानी ये तीन चीज से बना है इसलिए
ट्रायड कहते हैं इसको ये आपका बताता है कि
कोई डाटा आपका सिक्योर है इसके क्या
पैरामीटर्स है कोई डाटा की सिक्योरिटी को
मेजर करने के क्या पैरामीटर्स है वो
पैरामीटर्स क्या है कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी
इंटीग्रिटी एंड अवेलेबिलिटी इसका मतलब
क्या होता है इसका मतलब ये है
कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी मतलब आपका जो डाटा है
ठीक है वो सिर्फ ऑथेंटिकेटेड पर्सन या फिर
ऑथराइज पर्सन के पास होना चाहिए और कोई
इसको देखना पाए ठीक है आपको मैं
ऑथेंटिकेशन या ऑथराइज का डिफ बता देता हूं
ऑथराइज मतलब यह होता है कि किसके पास
परमिशन है ठीक है ऑथेंटिकेशन मतलब आप वो
बंदे है कि नहीं समझ रहे ऑथेंटिकेशन थरा
का मतलब क्या है मैं आपको य पर समझाने की
कोशिश करता हूं कोई बढ़िया वाइ बोर्ड खोल
लेते हैं
पहले चलिए जैसे यहां पर कोई बुक है ठीक है
कोई बुक है यहां पर यहां पर एक एक्स यूजर
को एक्सेस है ठीक है एक डाटा का वा यूजर
को एक्सेस है या फिर किसी किसी भी एडमिन
को एक्सेस है ठीक है एक एक्स यूजर को
एक्सेस है एक वा यूजर को एक्सेस है किसी
भी एडमिन को एक्सेस है अब ऑथराइजेशन क्या
है ऑथेंटिकेशन क्या है अगर कोई भी यूजर
ठीक है मान लीजिए कोई यूजर है जड ठीक है
जो इसको एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहा है
तो इसको क्या होगा इसको मना हो जाएगा
क्यों क्योंकि ही इज नॉट ऑथराइज्ड टू
एक्सेस दिस डाटा ठीक है बट अगर एक्स
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहा है एक्स अगर
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहा है तो ओके
क्यों क्योंकि ही इज ऑथराइज्ड टू एक्सेस द
डेटा ठीक है ये इसको जो है ऑथराइजेशन मिला
हुआ है कि आप इस डाटा को एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं लेकिन अगर ये जो z है ठीक है ये z अगर
बोलता है कि मैं z नहीं भाई मैं तो x हूं
ठीक है तो ये पता कैसे चलेगा इस प्रोसेस
को थ इंटीग्रेशन कहते हैं मतलब ये जो बता
रहा है कि भाई मैं z हूं ठीक है और वो जो
इंश्योर कर रहा है कि भाई तुम z हो या x
हो क्या हो वो ऑथेंटिकेशन है ठीक है तो
अगर ये बताता है कि मैं x हूं और
ऑथेंटिकेशन मै कजम में कोई दिक्कत है और
इसको लगता है इसको लगता है कि हां भाई वो
तो x ही बोल रहा है तो उसको अलाव कर देगा
क्योंकि x इ ऑथराइज्ड ट सस द डाटा ठीक है
ये डिफरेंस है ऑथराइजेशन और ऑथेंटिकेशन का
होप फुली समझ में आ गया होगा आप लोग को
चलिए तो कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी ठीक है मतलब सही
बंदे के पास एक्सेस होना चाहिए किसी को भी
डाटा का एक्सेस नहीं होना चाहिए ठीक है
जिसको अलाउड होना चाहिए उसी के पास होना
चाहिए चलिए अगला आता है इंटीग्रिटी अब
इंटीग्रिटी क्या है इंटीग्रिटी मतलब कि आप
है यहां पर ये आप क्लाइंट है ठीक है
क्लाइंट है आप और ये आपका सर्वर है सर्वर
है आपने कुछ रिक्वेस्ट किया ठीक है और
यहां से कुछ रिस्पांस आया ऐसी चीजें काम
करती है अब ना आपका रिक्वेस्ट ऑल्टर होना
चाहिए ना आपका रिस्पांस ऑल्टर होना चाहिए
मतलब आपका रिक्वेस्ट और रिस्पांस एज इटस
ट्रांसफर होना चाहिए बीच में कोई भी हैकर
या कोई भी किसी भी चीज का यहां पर जो है
डाटा में मैनिपुलेशन नहीं होना चाहिए मतलब
अगर हैकर बीच में आके डाटा को मैनिपुलेट
कर देता है तो आपकी जो डाटा की इंटीग्रिटी
है वो बिगड़ जाती है मतलब डाटा आपका वो
सेम नहीं रह गया जो पहले था और इसको चेक
करने के लिए एक बेसिक सी चीज आपको पता
होगी हम यहां पर हैश का इस्तेमाल करते हैं
अब हैश क्या होता है हैश मतलब जैसे मान
लीजिए यहां पर लिखा हुआ है ए बी सी या फिर
यहां पर लिखा हुआ है ए बी सी ठीक है ये
अलग-अलग है ना यहां ये कैपिटल है तो इसका
हैश और इसका हैश अलग आएगा ठीक है ये
एल्गोरिथम डिपेंड करता है बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं इस पे और इन सबका किसी भी एक
स्पेसिफिक सेट ऑफ डाटा का हैश हमेशा
कांस्टेंट रहेगा कहने का मतलब ये हैश कभी
चेंज नहीं हो सकता चाहे दुनिया के कोई भी
हैश रेटर का इस्तेमाल कीजिए तो अगर मैंने
ये डाटा भेजा है और मैंने इसका हैश पहले
ही भेजने से पहले ककट किया था कि ये हैश
है ठीक है और रिसीवर के पास ये डाटा जा
रहा है ठीक है क्योंकि बीच में हैकर ने
चेंज कर दिया जब रिसीवर के पास ये डटा
जाएगा रिसीवर के पास ठीक है और वो इस हैश
से इस हैश को कंपेयर करेगा इसका हैश निका
डल के तो वो मैच नहीं करेगा तो मतलब वो
समझ जाएगा कि यहां पर हमारी इंटीग्रिटी की
ऐसी की तैसी की गई है क्योंकि ये मैच नहीं
कर रहा है चलिए तो आप इंटीग्रिटी का मतलब
समझ गए होंगे अब नेक्स्ट आता है
अवेलेबिलिटी ठीक है अब इसका मतलब क्या
होता है इसका मतलब यह होता है कि जब डाटा
की जरूरत है तो डाटा उस टाइम अवेलेबल होना
चाहिए कहने का मतलब क्या इसका एक एग्जांपल
जब मैं आपसे बोलता हूं अगर आपको
अवेलेबिलिटी का मतलब पता है ऑलरेडी मतलब
सी ट्राइड में अवेलेबिलिटी क्या समझाना
चाहता है अगर आपको पता है तो आपके मन में
पहले एग्जांपल आता होगा हो सकता है कि डॉस
अटैक कि अगर वेबसाइट है कोई ठीक है उससे
बहुत सारे लोग अटैक कर देते हैं डीडीओ
अटैक कर देते हैं डॉस रक कर देते हैं
सिंगल ली बंदा करता है ठीक है और साइट
डाउन हो जाती है तो आपका क्या हो जाता है
ब साइट आपकी बंद होने के बाद आपकी
अवेलेबिलिटी को अफेक्ट करता है कहने का
मतलब कि जब यूजर्स यानी आपके जो कस्टमर है
वो जो वेबसाइट को ओपन करना चाहते हैं तो
वेबसाइट जो है वो ओपन नहीं होती है ठीक है
उनके लिए अवेलेबल नहीं होती है तो ये भी
आपके सिक्योरिटी के लेशन में आ गया लेकिन
इसके और भी एग्जांपल है सिर्फ यही नहीं
अगर आप एक डेली एग्जांपल देखना चाहे तो
रयर को भी आप कह सकते हैं ये भी
अवेलेबिलिटी को रोक देता है ठीक है कैसे
रोक देता है आपकी फाइल को एंक्रिप्ट कर
दिया आप डिक्रिप्ट नहीं कर पा रहे हैं
फाइल को एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे हैं अब
कैसे भी रोका हो डिलीट किया हो अ मतलब
आपको परमिशन रोक दिया हो या कैसे भी रोका
हो वो फॉर्म चेंज कर दिया एंक्रिप्ट कर
दिया लेकिन आपके डाटा को बिगाड़ दिया ना
आप एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते तो अवेलेबिलिटी को
वो अफेक्ट कर दिया ठीक है और जरूरी नहीं
है कि कोई अटैक मतलब सिर्फ एक ही कैटेगरी
में आ रहा है तीन दो कोई चीज पड़ सकती है
उस पे ठीक है तो ये सीआई ट्राइड उसकी डाटा
की सिक्योरिटी को इंश्योर कर रहा है अब
सुने होंगे आपने इफ यू आर बैड आई एम यूर
डेड वही वाली चीज है यहां पर अब डेड क्या
है यहां पर डेड मतलब डिस्क्लोजर अल्टरेशन
एंड डिस्ट्रक्शन ठीक है डिस्क्लोजर
अल्टरेशन एंड डिस्ट्रक्शन अब ये क्या होता
है ये इन तीन चीजों को खराब कर का पैमाना
है आप कह सकते हैं कहने का मतलब क्या
कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी कैसे ब्रेक हो सकती है
डिस्क्लोजर से अगर आपने इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोज कर दी तो अवेलेबिलिटी कैसे हो
सकती है डिस्ट्रक्शन से और इंटीग्रिटी
कैसे इफेक्ट हो सकती है अल्टरेशन से कैसे
आपने कोई चीज अवेलेबल करानी है वेबसाइट
आपकी अवेलेबल करानी है आप उसने हैकर ने
आपके वेबसाइट को डॉस कर दिया या फिर किस
तरीके से उस पर पूरा एक्सेस पाके उसकी
फाइल को डिलीट कर दिया इ डिस्ट्रक्शन कर
दिया तो अवेलेबिलिटी गई ना आपकी अल्टरेशन
आपके डटा में कु चेंज कर दिया डाटा को
अल्टर कर दिया ठीक है तो क्याल गया इ आपका
इंटीग्रिटी ठीक है तो ये वही चीज है
हालांकि ये
थोरेट्स
कैटेगरी में आता है मतलब अगर आपका सिर्फ
डॉस टैक मतलब एबिलिटी को इफेक्ट नहीं कर
रहा है और भी चीजें कर रही है या कोई एक
स्पेसिफिक नहीं है कि आपको हमेशा
इंटीग्रिटी आपके इफेक्ट सिर्फ नेटवर्क में
ही हो रही है कि नेटवर्क में डाटा शेयर कर
रहे थे बीच में आ गया क् एग्जांपल नहीं
दिए जाते हैं ना पर उसका मतलब ये नहीं कि
यहीं तक लिमिटेड है ठीक है कोई भी इस टाइप
कैटेगरी के अटैक को इसमें आप डाल सकते हैं
चलिए यहां पर वही चीज दिया हुआ एग्जांपल
वाइज दिया हुआ है जैसे कि यहां पर आप कोई
मैन द मिडिल अटैक यानी आप डाटा जो है
अल्टर कर रहे हैं नेटवर्क के बीच में आके
मतलब दो लोगों के कम्युनिकेशन के बीच में
आके ये आपका मै मिल अटैक कहलाता है ठीक है
ये आपकी इंटीग्रिटी को अफेक्ट कर रहा है
इस तरीके से यहां पे डॉस अटैक का एग्जांपल
दिया हुआ है जो मैंने अभी आपको समझाया वही
चीजें यहां पर दी हुई है तो कुछ इसमें नया
नहीं है
चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं इसको हम लोग यहां पर
कंप्लीट कर देते
हैं हां ओके ठीक है चलिए यहां पर आते हैं
अब एक-एक के डिटेल में ठीक है थोड़ा हम
लोग इसको डिटेल में समझेंगे अब स्नी फिंगर
टैक यहां पर बहुत ज्यादा प्रैक्टिकल अभी
नहीं होगा लेकिन नेक्स्ट हम एक चैलेंज
करने वाले हैं उसमें प्रैक्टिकल्स होंगे
इन चीजों के प्रैक्टिकल करना थोड़ा
मुश्किल है ठीक है मुश्किल मतलब यहां पे
दिखाना मुश्किल है क्योंकि लेवस में ये
पॉसिबल नहीं है सब दिखाना बट मैं इनके लिए
भी वीडियो होप फुली लाऊंगा ठीक है पर इनके
लिए अलग से वीडियो रहेगी तो वो प्रैक्टिकल
वीडियो ही रहेगी वो डिफरेंट चीज रहेगी पर
यहां पर आपको काफी कुछ सीखने को मिलने
वाला है तो वीडियो देखिएगा चलिए स्निफिंग
में आ गया अब स्निफिंग में क्या है आपको
मैंने रेडी बताया कि ऊपर जो हमने
प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में बात किए थे वो
कौन से प्रोटोकॉल थे क्लियर टेक्स
प्रोटोकॉल थे एनक्रिप्टेड नहीं थे वही चीज
यहां पे दी हुई है कि अगर कोई क्लियर
टेक्स प्रोटोकॉल का इस्तेमाल हो रहा है तो
आप बीच में जो भी नेटवर्क के बीच ट्रैफिक
है उसको सुन सकते हैं अब इसमें एक
इंपॉर्टेंट ध्यान रखना आपके लिए जरूरी है
वो चीज क्या है कि अगर आप किसी वायर
नेटवर्क में है जैसे आप नेटवर्क के बीच
में से वायर कनेक्ट कर रखे हैं आपने ठीक
है तो आप डाटा को सारा एक्सेस कर सकते हैं
सीधे वरना अगर आप वायरलेस नेटवर्क की बात
कर रहे हैं वाईफाई जैसे ऐसे नेटवर्क में
अगर आपको स्निफिंग करनी है तो आपको कोई
तरीका लगाना पड़ेगा कि सारे जो डाटा है वो
आपको थ्रू होते हुए जाए तो आपको इ वेंचुरी
मैन इ द मिडल अटैक ही करना पड़ेगा ठीक है
भले आप कुछ ऑल्टर कर रहे हो या ना कर रहे
हो तो स्निफिंग का यही काम है लेकिन अपने
सिस्टम के से गए हुए या फिर आपके सिस्टम
पे आए हुए पैकेट्स को तो आप कैप्चर कर ही
सकते हैं तो उनके लिए कुछ टूल्स है जैसे
टीसीपी डंप आप
विंडोज भी टी शर्क हो गया ठीक है इस टाइप
के टूल्स आप यूज कर सकते हैं तो मैं आपको
एक बार ये टूल दिखा भी देता हूं मेरे
ख्याल से मैंने पहले भी दिखाया हुआ है फिर
मैं एक बार आपको दिखा देता हूं ये अ ये
वाक मैंने ओपन कर लिया है इसमें मैं यहां
पर वाईफाई वाले प जाऊंगा अपने ये मेरा
वाईफाई वाला है एडेप्टर ठीक है इसको मैंने
ओपन कर लिया यहां पर सारे जो है डेटा
पैकेट वो दिख रहे हैं अब अगर मैं कोई
वेबसाइट खोलता हूं एचटीटीपी वाली ठीक है
क्योंकि मेरे को यहां पर कौन सा खोलना है
हमेशा लॉक वाला खोलना है सॉरी क्लियर
टेक्स्ट वाला खोलना है तो मैं मान लीजिए
लिखता हूं यहां पर टेस्ट पीएचपी व वेब
चलिए इसको ओपन करते हैं यूनिवर्सल साइट
एग्जांपल दिखाने के लिए मैं यहां पर देखता
हूं साइन अप का यहां पर पेज है ठीक है
साइन अप का य पर पेज है यहां पर मैं इसको
क्लियर कर देता हूं ताकि थ देखने में
आसानी हो और यहां पर लिख देते हैं
एचटीटीपी के लिए कि सिर्फ एचटीटीपी के जो
है रिक्वेस्ट यहां पर नजर आएंगे मैं इसको
रिफ्रेश करता हूं देखते हैं यहां पर कुछ
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही हैय देखिए एटीटीपी तो य
पर देख सकते हैं यहां पर ये एप्लीकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल के अर आप सारी सकते हैं गेट
रिक्वेस्ट की गई है लॉगइन पीएपी प होस्ट
ये रहा कनेक्शन ये रहा बाकी चीजें अब
इसमें तो कुछ बहुत सेंसिटिव है नहीं
सेंसिटिव कहां मिलेगा लॉगइन पे देखते हैं
यहां पर टोनिक्स
पासवर्ड में डाल दिया हमने टेस्ट करता हूं
उसको लॉग इन ये हो गया अब देखिए यहां पर
आपको यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट मिलेगी आपकी पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट यूजर इफ पीएचपी ये आपको यहां पर
मिलेगा आपका डाटा ये देखिए यूजर नेम ट
फोनिक्स और पासवर्ड टेस्ट ठीक है हमने
क्या किया हमने अपने डिवाइस से भेजा हुआ
ठीक है हम किया अपने डिवाइस से भेज हुए
पैकेट्स को कैप्चर किया अब चकि ये
क्लियरटेक्स्ट में जा रहा था इसलिए वो
कैप्चर हो गए क्लियरटेक्स्ट जाते तो आप
उसको रीड नहीं कर पाते ठीक है कैप्चर करने
के बाद भी अब यहां पर इंपोर्टेंट बात क्या
कि मैं तो अपने डिवाइस पे किया हूं अपने
डिवाइस पे करने से क्या होगा कुछ नहीं
होगा ै फयर नेटवर्क में रहिए या फिर आप
अपने और सॉरी अपने नहीं आप क्लाइंट और
सर्वर जिनके बीच में आपको घुसना है उनके
बीच के डाटा को अपने थ्रू पास करवाइए वो
चाहे आप मैन इ मट अटैक से कीजिए या कैसे
भी करिए वायर से करिए ठीक है चलिए तो इस
टाइप के टैक्स भी होते हैं इसमें क्या
होता है इन टैक्स में ये होता है कि आप
किसी दो डिवाइस के बीच में घुस जाते हैं
और उनके सारे इंफॉर्मेशन को सुन सकते हैं
इसीलिए क्लियर टेक्स प्रोटोकॉल नहीं य यूज
करने का ठीक है ना क्लियर टेक्स्ट
प्रोटोकॉल इसलिए नहीं यूज करना चाहिए अगर
आपने यहीं पे एचटीटीपीएस यूज किया होता
वेबसाइट में आपके वेबसाइट में एटीपीएस चल
रहा होता तो ये जो डाटा है ये कैप्चर होने
के बाद भी रीडेबल नहीं होता ठीक है बंदा
रीड नहीं कर पाता कि यहां पर कम्युनिकेशन
क्या हो रहा है क्या डाटा सेंड हो रहा है
ये रीडेबल नहीं होता ठीक है ना चलिए यहां
पर ये टूल का यूसेज दिया हुआ है आप टीसीपी
डम लिख के पोर्ट लिख सकते हैं कि कौन से
पोर्ट प आपको रिक्वेस्ट देखनी है ठीक है
यहां पर आपकी जो भी रिक्वेस्ट आएगी उसपे
आप उसको जो है देख सकते हैं चलिए यहां पर
ये टूल भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं आराम से
इसमें कुछ ऐसा खास है नहीं जैसे यहां पर
इन्होंने पॉप थ के लिए दिखाया था ठीक है
पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल थ्री के लिए यहां पर
इसने यूज़ करके दिखाया है आपको इसने यहां
पर रिक्वेस्ट को सारी एक्सेस की है और फिर
उसको यूज़ किया है तो यहां पर जो भी
डिटेल्स है वो सब आ रही है इसमें ऐसा कुछ
दिखाने लायक है नहीं खास लेकिन यहां पर
मेरे ख्याल से व्हाट डू यू नीड टू ऐड ठीक
है यहां पर कुछ क्वेश्चंस है प्रैक्टिकल
तो नहीं है मेरे ख्याल से इसका कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है च व्हाट डू यू नीड टू ऐड टू द
कमांड स्टू ट स्पीडम टू कैप्चर ओनली
टेलनेट ट्रैफिक आपको सिर्फ टेलनेट का
ट्रैफिक कैप्चर करना है यहां पर सिंटेक्स
में दिया हुआ है पोर्ट के बाद आप यहां पर
पोर्ट नंबर लिख लीजिए देखिए पोर्ट के
पोर्ट नंबर लिख लीजिए तो टेलनेट का पोर्ट
कौन सा होता है डिफॉल्ट 23 होता है तो लिख
दीजिए पोर्ट 23 हो गया व्ट इ द सिंपलेस्ट
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर यू कैन यूज विथ वाक टू शो
ओनली आई मैप ट्रैफिक जैसे मैंने अभी किया
था ना यहां पर मैंने एटीटीपी लिखा था
सिर्फ एचटीटीपी का आ गया जो भी ट्रैफिक था
ठीक है अब य पर सिंपल आई मैप लिखेंगे तो
सिंपल आई मैप का ट्रैफिक यहां पर आ जाएगा
ये तो के कुछ फिल्ट्रेशन टेक्निक है य
आपको या ने की जरूरत नहीं आपको ट शीट मिल
जाएंगी इसकी आपको नहीं या कर दीजिए यूज
करते वक्त ही को दिक्कत नहीं है उन चीजों
में ठीक है चलिए ये हो गया आपका का बेसिक
इंफॉर्मेशन कि स्निफिंग क्या होता है ठीक
है लेकिन ध्यान रखिए स्निफिंग में कभी आप
कुछ खास नहीं कर रहे मतलब आप बस बीच में
सुन रहे हैं ठीक है जब आप एक्टिवली उस में
इवॉल्व होते हैं मतलब अपने ट्रैफिक जो है
वो अपने थ्रू पास कराते हैं तो वो मैन इन
द मिडल अटैक में आ जाता है ठीक है मैन इन
द मिडिल अटैक में अब मैन इन द मिडल अटैक
बहुत सारे तरीके से हो सकता है लेकिन इसका
एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल मैं आपको यहां पर
बताना चाहूंगा जो होता है एईआरपी पॉइजनिंग
आप इसके बारे में जानते होंगे ए आरपी
पॉइजनिंग के बारे में इसमें हम क्या करते
हैं एक बार सोचिए अपने आपको जो है रिवाइंड
करने की कोशिश कीजिए पहले मैं यहां पर
पढता हूं बेसिक सा फिर मैं आपको यहां पर
समझाऊ एग्जांपल लेके चलिए देखिए यहां पर
क्या हो रहा है विक्टिम यहां पर जैसे दिया
हुआ है कि विक्टिम ए है ठीक है व्हेन अ
विक्टिम ए बिलीव्स दे आर कम्युनिकेटिंग
विथ द लेजिटिमेसी
बात कर रहा है ये मेरि द मिडल अटैक है
इसमें इंपैक्ट क्या पड़ा मान लीजिए इसने
ट्रांसफर रिक्वे बज की ट्रांसफर 20 ल ठीक
है टू m और इसने क्या चेंज कर दिया उसको
ट्रांसफर $2000 टू ए ठीक है डिफरेंस कर
दिया उसमें तो आपका काम का तो सतनास हो
गया अब एक इंपोर्टेंट चीज ये है जितना
आसानी से यहां पर लिखा हुआ है कि ड का 20
मिलियन डलर या सॉरी 000 उतना आसान नहीं
होता और हर चीज में होता भी नहीं सिक्योर
होता है लेकिन आपको ये जस्ट एग्जांपल दिया
है ठीक है इसको इतना लाइटली मत ले लीजिएगा
लेकिन समझने वाले के लिए यही चीज थी चलिए
य पर और क्या लिखा हुआ है यहां पर लिखा
हुआ है बहुत सारे यहां पर टूल्स यूज कर
सकते हैं इनके लिए जैसे आपका एटर कैप हो
गया बेटर कैप हो गया ठीक है इस टा के बहुत
सारे टूल्स है उनका यूज कर सकते हैं आपको
अ से दिखाना पड़ेगा ठीक है चलिए वही चीज
है यहां पर लिखा हुआ है रिट सिंपल टू कैरी
आउट इ टू पार्टी नट कम द टी एंड
इंटीग्रिटी ऑफ इच मैसेज मतलब कंफर्म नहीं
कर रहे हैं तो ए आरपी पंग जैसे केस में ये
सब हो जाता है जैसे कि ए आरपी का मतलब
आपको बताता हूं मैं ए आरपी मतलब आपको पता
होगा ए आरपी लिखता हूं मैं यहां पर मैंने
पढ़ाया भी है आपको ये चीज ए आरपी आपका ये
होता है क्या एड्रेस र य लिखता नहीं हूं
पूरा ए आरपी आपका होता है एड्रेस
रेजोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल ठीक है ये क्या काम
करता है ये कुछ इस तरीके काम करता है मान
लीजिए यहां पर एक डिवाइस है ठीक है आपका
एक डिवाइस है य है आपका यह बी है आपका ठीक
है य पर और डिवा मा लीजिए सी है आपका ठीक
है यह आपका राउटर है ठीक है राउटर है अब
अगर ए को ए को अगर किसी से बात करनी है
ठीक है अगर ए का आईपी एड्रेस एक्स है ठीक
है और मैक एड्रेस वा ख आई ऊपर लिख रहा
नीचे लिख रहा हूं ठीक है
आईपी और ये कन्वेंशन में सब में फॉलो करने
वाला हूं अभी नना आपको आसान
होगा चलिए आईपी इसका एक्स है ठीक है और
मैक एड्रेस इसका क्या है वा है अब इसको
क्या करना है इसको बी से बात करनी है ठीक
है और बी का आईपी क्या है बी का आईपी है
जड ठीक है और मैक है बी ठीक है इसको इससे
बात करनी है तो ये क्या करेगा जो ए है ठीक
है ये एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा ठीक है
ब्रॉडकास्ट मैक पे ठीक है ये एक रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेगा ब्रॉडकास्ट मैक पे ब्रॉडकास्ट मैक
मतलब एक एड्रेस होता है एफ एफ एफ कॉलन
करके ऐसे उसका मतलब है कि हर डिवाइस भेज
दो वो ठीक है प्र क्या पूछेगा कि जो आईपी
एड्रेस x है ठीक है नहीं सॉरी जो आईपी
एड्रेस आपका z है ज से बात करनी है ना
पूछेगा z कहां पे है समझे ये पूछेगा z भाई
कहां पे हो तुम जड भैया कहां पे हैं आप
ठीक है अब यह रिक्वेस्ट सबके पास गई अ ज
सबके पास गई तो जहां पे z है z बताएगा कि
हां भैया मेरे पास है और z अपना बी यानी
मैक एड्रेस भी भेज देगा ठीक है z अपना
क्या करेगा मैक एड्रेस भेज देगा ठीक है अब
क्या हुआ a को बी का मैक एड्रेस मिल गया
अब जब a को बी का मैक एड्रेस मिल गया तो
अब ए आगे जो भी कम्युनिकेशन करना होगा a
अपने पास एक टेबल रखेगा जिसमें वो आईपी और
मैक दोनों रखेगा तो ए समझ जाएगा कि ठीक है
भाई ये जो आईपी एड्रेस है जड ठीक है वो
मैक बी के पास है तो आगे जो भी डाटा जड को
भेजना है डाटा बी के मैक एड्रेस प भेज दो
ठीक है मैं आपको इसको एग्जांपल से मतलब
सॉरी यहां पर डायग्राम से समझाने की कोशिश
करता हूं एक और होता थोड़ा आपको समझने में
यहां पर दिक्कत हुआ हो रिपीट भी कर
लीजिएगा आप मैं दोबारा दिखाता हूं यहां पर
दोबारा समझाता हूं अच्छे से इमेजस खोल
लेते हैं यहां पर एक बढ़िया
सी कोई बढ़िया एग्जांपल मिल जाए यहां पर थ
समझना भी इजी हो जाएगा आपके लिए
ये देख लीजिए जैसे यहां पर बॉब है और मैरी
है ठीक है बॉब के पास य पर मैक एड्रेस
दिया हुआ है ए वाला और ये इसका है बीबी
वाला ठीक है अब हमें क्या करना है हमें
बॉब और मैरी है ठीक है ए आरपी पॉज में
क्या हो रहा है अभी क्या हो रहा है सिंपल
अभी नीचे भूल जाइए ये पार्ट नीचे वाला जो
है उसको भूल जाइए अभी समझिए सिर्फ बॉब और
मेरी की बात करनी है तो बॉब के पास आईपी
एड्रेस है मेरी का उस आईपी एड्रेस रीच
करने के लिए उसको मेरी का मैक एड्रेस भी
चाहिए होगा तो वो क्या करेगा एक
ब्रॉडकास्ट मैक एड्रेस वा रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेगा ब्रॉडकास्ट मैक रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा
ठीक है जो क्या रहेगी जो हर एक डिवाइस प
चली जाएगी नेटवर्क के हर एक डिवाइस प चली
जाएगी अब जब वो रिक्वेस्ट मैरी को मिलेगी
बाकी डिवाइस तो इग्नोर कर देंगे उसको जब
वो मैरी को मिलेगी मैरी कहेगी अरे भाई ये
तो मेरे ही आईपी एड्रेस को पूछ रहा है तो
मैरी क्या करेगी मैरी अपनी तरफ से एक
रिप्लाई भेजेगी और बोलेगी कि हां भाई इस
आईपी एड्रेस को तुम खोज रहे थे और अपना
मैक लगा देगी वो इस मैक एड्रेस पे अवेलेबल
है बॉब को मिल गया बॉब ने आईपी एड्रेस और
मैक एड्रेस को रख लिया ठीक है अब बॉ आप
काम हो गया अब आपको जब भी कोई डाटा भेजना
है उसको भेजेगा ठीक है अब एर पॉसिंग में
क्या होता है एर पॉसिंग में ये होता है कि
हमने क्या किया हमने वो रिस्पांस बिना
किसी रिक्वेस्ट के ठीक है मतलब हमने क्या
किया हमने कोई भी मतलब जैसे बॉब रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रहा था त मैं रिप्लाई कर रही थी ठीक
है लेकिन अगर बॉब रिक्वेस्ट नहीं भेज रहा
है तो भी हम उसको रिप्लाई भेज रहे हैं
अपनी तरफ से और हम बता रहे हैं कि भैया ये
जो आईपी एड्रेस तुम खोजने वाले हो ठीक है
यानी मैरी का आईपी एड्रेस ठीक है जो मेरी
का आईपी एड्रेस जो तुम खोजने वाले हो वो
आईपी एड्रेस मेरे पास है और मैक मैं अपना
दे दूंगा मतलब आईपी एड्रेस मैंने मेरी का
दिया और मैक मैंने अपना दे दिया इससे क्या
होगा कि अगली बार जब बॉब को कोई डाटा
भेजना होगा मेरी को तो बॉब पहले टेबल में
चेक करेगा आपने कि भाई मेरे पास इसका
एड्रेस है कि नहीं है नहीं है तो मैं
रिक्वेस्ट करूं लेकिन बॉब देखेगा कि अरे
मेरे पास तो पहले से जो है डाटा भरा हुआ
है तो देखेगा कि ठीक है मुझे जो आईपी
एड्रेस भेजना है उसपे मैक एड्रेस का है अब
तो मैरी के आईपी एड्रेस पे अटैकर का मैक
एड्रेस हो गया तो वो जो भी डाटा भेजेगा वो
कहां भेजेगा अटैकर को भेजेगा समझ में आया
आपको उम्मीद करता हूं समझ में आ गया होगा
ऑलरेडी मैंने समझाया हुआ है मेरे ख्याल से
इसको एक और बार तो आपको दिक्कत तो नहीं
होनी चाहिए उससे फिर भी अगर दिक्कत है तो
पूछ लीजिएगा दोबारा से चलिए मोटा-मोटा यही
मतलब था कि आप नेटवर्क में दो लोगों के
बीच में आके आपका जो डाटा है वो आपके थ
ट्रांसर हो रहा है ठीक है इस तरीके से आप
मैन मिडल अटैक करते हैं है और अगर आपका जो
प्रोटोकॉल से कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है अगर
वो क्लियर टेक्स्ट हुआ तो ये बीच वाला
बंदा हर चीज देख पाएगा वरना अगर ये
एचटीटीपीएस रहा तो भाई तुम बीच में आओ
चाहे जहां हो तुम डाटा नहीं कर सकते कुछ
नहीं उखाड़ सकते तुम्हारा ठीक है अगर बीच
में हमारा जो प्रोटोकॉल यूज हो रहा है वो
सिक्योर है तो ठीक है इसीलिए सिक्योर
प्रोटोकॉल यूज करना सबसे जरूरी होता है
चलिए अ आपको समझ में आ गया होगा ये भी
कैसे काम कर रहा है इस क्वेश्चन देख लेते
हैं हाउ मेनी डिफरेंट इंटरफेस डि एटर कैप
ऑफर मेरे ख्याल से टू देख लेते
हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है देख लेते इसका
क्या आंसर
है एटर कैप के तो एक ही इंटरफेस होते है
मेरे ख्याल
से एटर कैप
इंटरफेस
ओके ठीक है चार य पर इंटरफेस हैप में इसका
मतलब क्या बताता हूं आपको मैं चार ते चार
ही आ र है चार नहीं और भी है क्या लते हैं
इसको देखते हैं कितने है
टोटल ओके एक दो तीन चार चार ही तो है
यार पूछा है
ना देख लेते हैं यहां से बेसिकली है तो
चार ही पर यहां पर भी यार वही पेज तो है य
भी
चलिए ठीक है देख लेते हैं मेरे खल से कुछ
नए इंटरफेस भी है क्या इसमें डिपेंडेंसी
हो गई आपकी
य डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन हो गया डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन
हो गया इंटरफेस कहां है
आपके ओ वेट करें इसको लंबा आंसर तो नहीं
चाहिए
चलिए देख लेते हैं ऐसे ही
करके ओके
तीन ठीक है वैसे यहां पर तीन आ रहा है पर
यहां पर चार दिया हुआ है मैं क इसको काउंट
नहीं किया इसीलिए ठीक है अब इंटरफेस का
मतलब क्या है सिंपल इंटरफेस का मतलब ये है
कि किस तरीके से आपको ट को चलाना है जीवाई
में चलाना है कमांड लाइन में चलाना है या
किस तरीके से चलाना है ठीक है वही चीज है
कोई मतलब नहीं है इसका ठीक है चलिए तीन
इंटरफेस है तो टूल बेस चीज है इन हाउ मेनी
वेज कैन यू इवोक बेटर कैप अब बेटर कैप के
कितने है ठीक है इसका भी वही सेम चीज है
क्या मतलब है इसको डायरेक्टली ट्राई कर
लेते हैं
खत्म करते हैं
इसको चलिए तीन इसके भी है बाकी इसको क्लोज
कर देते हैं अभी के लिए हम लोग ये आप
टूल्स के जो भी है आप वर्किंग को या फिर
इनके अबाउट पे जाके आप पढ़ सकते हैं कि
भाई और उसका हेल्प मेन्यू या फिर मेन पेज
होता है ना मैनुअल पेज उसमें देख सकते हैं
तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है इन चीजों में चलिए
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं अभी के लिए कुछ
खास है नहीं इसमें टी एलएस पे आते हैं अब
ये काफी जरूरी है इस रूम का ये काफी
इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक होने वाला है ठीक है अब
एक चीज मैं आपको बता दूं कि यहां पर टी
एलएस का जो हैंड शेक है वो ब टम कैसे काम
कर रहा है वो मैं आपको अभी नहीं बताने
वाला वरना वो दिमाग सेपर जाएगा नहीं आएगा
लेकिन हम समझेंगे एक मोटे तरीके पे कि किस
तरीके से टीएस काम कर रहा है ठीक है और
बाद में हम लोग जब मैं मैंने आपको कहा कि
मैं अगर आप कोशिश करूंगा अगर आपके लिए मैं
एमआईटीएम स् फिंग इ सबका अगर प्रैक्टिकल
ला पाऊं
youtube's क्या है ठीक है अब तक हमने क्या
समझ लिया अब तक हमने ये समझा कि जो भी
प्रोटोकॉल हमने समझा वो दिक्कत दे रहे हैं
ठीक है क्या-क्या दिक्कत दे सकते हैं वो
हमने समझा प करने का क्याक दिक्कत हो सकता
है अब वो दिक्कत को ओवरकम कैसे करना है
ठीक है दिक्कत किससे हो रहा है क्या हो
रहा है वो तो समझ गए दिक्कत का सॉल्यूशन
क्या है सॉल्यूशन ये है कि भाई तुम ऐसा
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ करो जो कि एनक्रिप्टेड हो
अब हर प्रोटोकॉल का एनक्रिप्टेड वर्जन को
हम क्या कह सकते हैं हम वहां पर
एंक्रिप्शन कैसे प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं
उनके लिए कुछ नए प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं ठीक है
वो कैसे काम कर रहे हैं दिखाता हूं आपको
मैं टी एलएस का इस्तेमाल करते हैं हम लोग
टी एलएस क्या है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सिक्योरिटी अब आपने एसल भी सुना होगा पहले
हम कहते हैं ना कि वेबसाइट पे एसएल लगा
हुआ है कि नहीं लगा हुआ है एल सर्टिफिकेट
है कि नहीं है ठीक है उसका अपग्रेडेशन आप
क सकते हैं एक तरीके से ि हम लोग इसको दो
वड को यूज़ करते हैं ठीक है लेकिन अलग-अलग
है थोड़ा सा अंतर है ठीक है चलिए तो अगर
आप इसको ओआई मॉडल प देखते हैं ठीक है तो
ओआई मॉडल के हिसाब से आपके जो ये जो
प्रोटोकॉल चल रहे हैं एटीटीपी एफटीपी
एटीपी पप 3 आ या जो भी हम यूज कर रहे हैं
ये सब आपके एप्लीकेशन र प्रोटोकॉल है
क्योंकि इनका जो वर्क है वो एप्लीकेशन
लेयर पे है ठीक है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर क्या
चल रहे हैं टीसीपी यूडीपी की कैसे
ट्रांसपोर्ट करना है नेटवर्क लेयर पे आईपी
एड्रेस चल रहे हैं ठीक है लेकिन
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पे आप यहां पर एसल या
टीलर का इस्तेमाल करते हैं अब ये
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर क्या करती है
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पे आप इसको एक
एनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में प्रेजेंट करा सकते
हैं ठीक है आप इसको एनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में
प्रेजेंट कर सकते हैं ताकि आपका जो डाटा
है वो एनक्रिप्टेड जाए ठीक है और यहां से
जाता रहेगा तो प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पे
एंक्रिप्ट हो जाएगा आते हुए यहां पे
डिक्रिप्ट हो जाएगा तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
रहेगी ठीक है एंक्रिप्ट होने के बाद बीच
में अगर उसको कोई पकड़ता है डाटा को तो वो
समझ नहीं पाएगा कि क्या लिखा हुआ है या
क्या है ठीक है ये आपका फायदा करेगा एसएल
या फिर टीएल एस अब एसएल पुराना हो गया है
टी एलएस उससे नया है लेकिन आज भी एसएल यूज
होता है तो उसमें कोई चिंता नहीं है पर टी
एलएस ज्यादा सिक्योर माना जाता है चलिए हम
यहां पर अपने इन सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स में टी
एलएस यूज कर सकते हैं बहुत लोग सोचते हैं
कि नहीं सिर्फ एटीटीपी में होगा नहीं इन
सब में यूज़ हो सकता है ठीक है इन सब में
टी एलएस यूज़ हो सकता है अब टी एलएस किस
तरीके से काम करता है टी एलएस लगाने के
बाद इन प्रोटोकॉल्स के ऊपर टी एलएस लगाने
के बाद ठीक है कुछ न प्रोटोकॉल्स बनते हैं
जिनको हम यहां पर ये उनके अल्टरनेटिव आप
समझ सकते हैं एटीटीपी को हम एचटीटीपीएस
कहते हैं ठीक है जिसका डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट ये
होता है 443 वाला ठीक है ये सारे डिफॉल्ट
पोर्ट वाले दिए हुए हैं एफटीपी जिनका
डिफॉल्ट पोट 21 होता है उसका एफटीपीएस
होता है ठीक है जो 990 होता है अब एक एस
एफटीपी भी होता है ठीक है वो डिफरेंट हो
गया वो एएच और एफटीपी का कॉमिनेशन होता है
ठीक है ये एटीपीएस है ठीक है यानी एफटीपी
सिक्योर ठीक है ये सब यहां पर एस स्टैंड
फॉर सिक्योर यहां पर सारे में ठीक है
एटीपी सिक्योर पथ सिक्योर आ सिक्योर ठीक
है ये इही सब सेम प्रोटोकॉल है ठीक है वही
काम काम करते हैं बस इसमें एक टी एलएस की
जो लेयर है वो एक्स्ट्रा ऐड हो गई है अब
ये टीएस की लेयर जो है काम कैसे कर रही है
वो कुछ इस तरीके से काम कर रही है देखिए
सबसे पहले जब हमें कोई वेब सर्वर रीच करना
होता है ठीक
है हमें कोई यहां पर वेब सर्वर रीच करना
होता है जैसे हमारा यहां पर मान लीजिए
सर्वर है ठीक है और यहां पर हमारा ये है
एक एक
ओके यह हमारा य पर एक क्लाइंट ठीक है यह
मान लीजिए वेब सर्वर है आपका रा क्लांट है
इसने क्या भेजा इसने भे य पर सिंपल एक गेट
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है और य पर क्या गयास ठीक
है जो भी रिस्प था रिपस आ गया अब यह सब
शुरू होने से पहले भी क्या हुआ सब श होने
से पहले एक चीज और हुआ था ठीक है और हु था
वो था आपका
टीसीपी हैंड शेक ठीक है टीसीपी हैंड शेक
समझे टीसीपी हैंड शक हुआ था कहने का मतलब
क्या कहने का मतलब सिंपल सा ये है कि ये
आप है क्लाइंट ये आप है सर्वर ठीक है यहां
पर आपका टीसीपी टीसीपी का हैंड शेक पूरा
हुआ पहले ठीक है यह कंप्लीट होने के बाद
तब यहां पर गेट पोस्ट जो भी रिक्वेस्ट और
रिस्पांस है वो कंप्लीट हुआ ठीक है तो ये
दो स्टेप फॉलो थे ठी दो स्टेप मेन थे ये
जैसे कि यहां पर लिखा भी हुआ है वही चीज
लिखी हुई है सेम ठीक है यहां पर नहीं
एक्चुअली शायद ऊपर दी हुई थी बट कोई नहीं
कोई नहीं पड़ता मैं बताता हूं आपको
अपने हिसाब से ठीक है इस तरीके से काम हो
रहा है लेकिन यहां पर टी एलएस वाले में
क्या हो रहा है ठीक है अगर आप कोई भी
प्रोटोकॉल में टीएल जोड़ दे रहे हैं तो
एक्स्ट्रा काम क्या हो रहा है सबसे पहले
एक टीसीपी कनेक्शन बन रहा है ठीक है सबसे
पहले एक आपका टीसीपी कनेक्शन बन रहा है
ठीक है फिर आपका एक टी एलएस या फिर एसएसएल
का कनेक्शन भी बन रहा है ठीक है एसएसएल
या टी एलएस का आपका कनेक्शन भी बन रहा है
ठीक है इसके बाद आपका सेम जो चीज हो रहा
है वही हो रहा है ठीक है सेम वर्क हो रहा
है कोई डिफरेंस नहीं हुआ देखिए एस्टेब्लिश
टीसीपी कनेक्शन पहले होता है फिर यहां पर
गेट पोस्ट को रिक्वेस्ट वो भेजते हैं आप
लेकिन एसल या टी एलएस में एक एक्स्ट्रा
एक्स्ट्रा ऐड हो जाता है पहले टीसीबी
कनेक्शन बना फिर एएल या टीलर कनेक्शन बना
फिर आपका जो रिक्वेस्ट है जैसे एज इट इज
वो जा रहा है अब वो इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में
जा रहा है अब ये कैसे हो रहा है एसल हैंड
चेक ये मैं यही कह रहा था कि ये आपको मैं
डिटे प अभी नहीं समझाऊं ठीक है ये
प्रैक्टिकल होगा तो आपको समझा पाऊंगा
अच्छे से ऐसे ब समझ नहीं आएगा लेकिन एक
मोटा मोटा आपको समझा रहा हूं कि यहां पर
हो क्या रहा है यहां पर हो ये रहा है कि
जब यहां पर पहले एक टीसीपी कनेक्शन जो है
एस्टेब्लिश हुआ ठीक है टीसीपी कनेक्शन में
क्या हुआ टीसीपी कनेक्शन में सबसे पहले ये
आपका क्लाइंट है ये आपका सर्वर है यार
सबसे पहले आपका यहां पर गया सिन आपको पता
ही है ऑलरेडी मैंने आपको बहुत बार समझा
चुका हूं ये सिन ठीक है यहां से आया आपका
सिन एक ठीक है सिन एक और यहां से क्या गया
एक ठीक एक्नॉलेजमेंट कनेक्शन का बन गया अब
अब इस पाइपलाइन के समझ लीजिए इसके अंदर
सारी एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट आना जाना सब हो
रहा है ठीक है और ये सब कंप्लीट होने के
बाद यहां पर फिनिश भेज दिया गया और आपका
काम खत्म हो गया ठीक है इस तरीके से आपका
क्या काम करता है ी कनेक्शन के अंदर अब
यहां पर दो जगह रुकेंगे आप रुकूंगा आपको
एक यहां पर टीसी कनेक्शन बनने के बाद यहां
पर और एक फिनिश होने से पहले ठीक है यहां
पर आपका एसएसएल भी काम कर रहा है ठीक है
अब एसएसएल के भी पहले यहां पर क्या बन रहे
हैं एएल का कनेक्शन बन रहा है और उसके
अंदर रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है अब ये कनेक्शन
बनने का तरीका है इसमें ठीक है क्लाइंट
हेलो सर्वर हेलो यहां पर सर्टिफिकेट
एक्सचेंज का काम हो रहा है और यहां पर की
के थ्रू सर्टिफिकेट वेरीफाई हो रहा है ठीक
है कि सर्टिफिकेट सही थट का है कि नहीं आप
इसको कुछ इस तरीके से समझ सकते हैं कि आप
जैसे कोई वेबसाइट खोल रहे हैं google.com
ठीक है
बिगड़ जाएगा अब ये चीज आपको हो सकता है
अभी बहुत अच्छे से समझ ना आ रही हो और मैं
ऐसे समझा भी नहीं पाऊंगा बहुत अच्छे तरीके
से इसको क्योंकि इसको थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकल
समझाना पड़ेगा तो मैं आपको आगे समझाऊ जरूर
इतना समझिए कि ये काम कर रहा है इस तरीके
से काम कर रहा है आपका टी एलएस ठीक है आप
ये पढ़ सकते हैं लेकिन कोई मतलब नहीं है
वही चीज आपको भी य समझने में थोड़ा दिक्कत
होगा लेकिन मतलब वही है ठीक है अगर आपका
बैकग्राउंड इस पे है पहले आपने काम किया
स्निफिंग पफिंग सब चीजों पे तो आपको समझना
थोड़ा इजी हो जाएगा नहीं तो आपको अभी तक
के लिए इतना समझ लीजिए बस कि ऐसे ही काम
कर रहा है बाकी जब मैं प्रैक्टिकल गा
पाऊंगा तो मैं ये भी लगा दूंगा उसमें चलिए
व यहां पर दिया हुआ है कुछ नया नहीं है
यहां पर यहां पर एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है
ब्राउजर में जाके इंपोर्ट सर्टिफिकेट करते
हैं जब आप ब इंस्टॉल करते तो भी आप करते
हैं य देख सकते हैं वहां पर क्या चीज है
सर्टिफिकेट व्यूअर ठीक है सर्टिफिकेट है य
पर सर्टिफिकेट 30 नेशन सब दिया हुआ है
किसने सर्टिफिकेट इशू किया है ठीक है
किसके लिए इशू हुआ है हर चीज ठीक है यहां
पर दी हुई है इस मतलब समझाऊ अ सता अच्छे
से लेकिन आपको मैं इसको प्रैक्टिकल से
दिखाने की कोशिश करूंगा चलिए डीएनएस कैन
आल्सो बी सेक्यर्ड यूजिंग टी एलएस व्ट इज
द थ्री लेटर अनिंग ऑफ डीएनएस प्रोटोकॉल
दैट यूस टीएल एस ठीक है टीएल एस यूज करने
वाला डीएनएस प्रोटोकॉल क्या कहते हैं ये
पूछा गया है यहां पर देख लेते हैं नाम
यहां पर इसका क्या है डीएनएस के लिए मे
ख्याल से यहां पर दिया नहीं है क्या दिया
तो होगा ही
वैसे य नहीं दिया हुआ है सर्च कर लेते हैं
ग प को कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है डीएनएस
विथ डीएलएस
प्रोटेक्शन चलिए डीएलएस ओवर टी एलएस इसको
हम डीएनए सेक
भी ठीक है इसका थ्री वर्ड का ही चाहिए
हमें ी वड का शॉर्टकट हम क्या कते
हैं डीन कहते हैं क्या वास देख लेते इसका
ठीक है क्या ट द है इसने ग पम मिल जाएगा
इसका देखना पड़ेगा
हमें ओके ठीक है डीएनएस ओवर टीस डॉट इसको
हम डॉट कहते हैं डीन ओवर लस चलिए हो गया
अने जरूरत नहीं आपको य पता चाहि ठीक है
भाई डीन काम राडिन नहीं बाकी ऐसे सारे
प्रोटोकॉल जितने भी क्ट प्रोटोकॉल है वो
आपके काम कर जाएंगे टी एलएस पे ठीक है
टीएस लग जाएगा ये आपको बताना चाहिए बाकी
तो आप समझ ही सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
चलिए यहां पर एसए की बात कर लेते हैं एसए
के बारे में तो भाई कितनी बार बात की है
हमने इसमें कुछ है नहीं खास बात करने के
लिए वही चीज पूरी दी हुई है ठीक है कि एएच
क्या होता है कैसे होता है सब हमने ऑलरेडी
बात कर रखा है पूरे मॉड्यूल में डिटेल में
एक चीज यहां पर एक्स्ट्रा दी हुई है वो
आपका मेरे ख्याल से यहां पर हां एससीपी है
ठीक है हां एक चीज और बता दूं आपको यहां
पर एएच के बारे में अलग से क्यों दिखाया
गया है इसलिए क्योंकि एएच क्लियर टे
प्रोटोकॉल नहीं है हमने ऑलरेडी बात किया
हुआ है एसए एक क्लियर टेक्स्ट प्रोटोकॉल
नहीं है टेलनेट से इसको रिप्लेस किया गया
था सॉरी टेलनेट को रिप्लेस किया गया था
इससे ठीक है एस से इसीलिए क्योंकि टेलनेट
आपका क्लिय टेस्ट प्रोटोकॉल था एफटीपी
आपका क्लियर टेस्ट है लेकिन एस आपका
क्लियर टेस्ट पहले से ही नहीं है तो एस तो
भाई सेफ है ऑलरेडी इस मामले में ठीक है
इसलिए यहां पर एसस की बात हो रही है
चलिए यहां पर आप एससीपी टूल का यूज कर
सकते हैं अगर आप किसी भी डिवाइस कनेक्टेड
है आप सिंपल यहां पर एससीपी एक यूटिलिटी
होती है जिसको हम कह सकते हैं यहां पर एस
सेक्यर कॉपी प्रोटोकॉल ठीक है कक एस
प्रोटोकॉल के प बेस्ड है एससीपी लिख अपने
सिस्टम में ठीक है यहां पर अपने एसएस की
डिटेल लिखिए ठीक है अपना यूजर नेम ट आईपी
एड्रेस ठीक है फ कोलन लगा के आपको वहां पर
उसके यूजर पर कौन सी फाइल लेनी है और कहां
पर कॉपी करनी है व आप लिख सकते फाइल को
अपने सिस्टम से किसी एस जहा कनेक्ट करेंगे
वहां पर कॉपी कर सकते हैं वहां से अपने
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं ठीक इसका प्रैक्टिकल
हम देखने वाले हैं चलिए प्रैक्टिकल करने
के लिए दिया हुआ है इसको हम लोग कॉपी कर
लेते हैं पहले लिखा हुआ है यूज द एस टू
कनेक्ट टू आईपी एड्रेस एस मार्क विद द
पासवर्ड ये ठीक है हम क्या करना है हमें
एसज करना है इसमें तो हम यहां पर ओपन कर
लेते हैं एसज करना है यूजर हमारा क्या है
मार्क है कनेक्ट करते हैं इसको पेस्ट कर
देते हैं यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस को ठीक है
इसको एंटर करते हैं इसको यस कर देते हैं
पासवर्ड हम यहां पर कॉपी कर लेते हैं अपना
ठीक है अभी आपको समझाऊ य एससी वाला क्या
चीज है सॉरी यहां पर मैं कंट्रोल व कर
दिया
शिफ्ट ओके हम कनेक्ट कर चुके हैं ऑलरेडी
पहला काम हमारा यहां पर क्या था य नेम
दिखना है यहां पर कनल का नेम दिखना है ये
कनल का हमारा नेम है इसको हम लोग कंपलीटली
ए इट कॉपी कर लेते हैं और हम इसको यहां पर
पेस्ट कर देते हैं चलिए यूज एस टू डाउनलोड
द फाइल बक फ्रॉम द रिमोट सिस्टम हाउ मेनी
केवी ड एससीपी डिस्प्ले डाउनलोड साइज अब
मतलब क्या देखिए अब मैं आपको समझाता हूं
इसको प्रैक्टिकल अच्छे तरीके से पर एलस
करूंगा तो एक फाइल रखी हुई यहां पर देखिए
बुक डटी ठीक है अब ये बुक हमें चाहिए कहां
पे अपने सिस्टम पे तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं
पहले हम यहां पर एग्जिट कर ले ठीक है हम
क्या लिखेंगे एससीपी लिखेंगे ठीक है फिर
हमें कहां से कॉपी करनी है हमें मार्क
यूजर से कॉपी करनी है जो कि कौन से सॉरी
जो कि कौन से सर्वर पर बैठा हुआ है जो
बैठा हुआ है
आपका क गया आई एडस हमारा ओके 10 10 153
168 ड बैठा हुआ है ठीक है फ कलन लगा के हम
लिखेंगे वहा से हम कौन सी फाइल चाहिए तो
वहा से हमें बुक डॉटी एक्सटी चाहिए ठीक है
हो सकता है किसी फोल्डर के अंदर होती तो य
पर फोल्डर भी लिखते कंपलीट लिखते ठीक है
अब स्पेस दीजिए और लिख आपको अपने सिस्टम प
कहां चाहिए अब मैं डॉट लगा देता हूं डॉट
मतलब करंट लोकेशन प चाहिए ठीक है एंटर
करता हूं पासवर्ड पूछेगा पूछेगा ही बिना
पास तो करेगा नहीं कॉपी करते हैं इसको य
पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं पेस्ट एंटर करते हैं
ठीक है देखिए
बुक हो गया य पर एस करते
हैं आ गया
करते य देखि य पर जो भी इमेशन थी मिल गई
करता हूं क्वेश्चन क्या था हमारा क्वेश्चन
था हमारा अ ताना था तो मेरे खल से हम
इसमें वर्बोस मोड में जाना पड़ेगा ठीक है
हम देखना पड़ेगा मेरे ल से वर्ब मोड में
जाने के लिए लो करते हु सार इमेशन है मिल
जाए देखते हैं एससीपी के लिए हेल्प देख
लेते हैं पर वर्ब्स का ऑप्शन तो होना
चाहिए ओके ठीक है यहां पर ऑप्शन नहीं है
मेरे ख्याल से कोई दिक्कत नहीं है लो कर
डायरेक्टली चेक कर लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है चलिए परस का ऑप्शन नहीं है हम लोग
यहां पर फाइ डाउलोड करते हैं पेस्ट करता
हूं इसको मैं से अच्छा ओके ठीक है यहां पर
दिखा रहा है ये 415 के डउनलोड हुई है ठीक
है ये ना दिखा रहा लोग फाइल की साइज देख
सते डायरेक्टली तो मालूम चल जाता ठीक है
415 केब है यहां
पर सबमिट हो गया अब चलिए ये आप समझ गए
होंगे यहां पर एसस का काम और एससीपी कैसे
यूज करते हैं ठीक है ये एससीपी का आपको
काफी यूज होगा सीटीएफ में भी और बहुत सार
जगह जहां आपको अपने डाटा को भेजना होगा
रिमोट सिस्टम पे ठीक है
चलिए अब बात कर लेते हैं यहां पर पासवर्ड
अटैक के बारे में यहां पर ये भी आप लोग को
मोटा-मोटा पता ही है पासवर्ड अटैक हमने
हाइड्रा से उतनी बार किया है लेकिन ये सब
मैं आपको इसलिए करा रहा हूं कि ये छोटा सा
क्क रिवीजन भी कर रहा है ठीक है और क्वेरी
टर्म से आपको यहां पर फैमिल आइज भी करा
रहा है जैसे खास टीएस के बारे में इस लोग
को पता नहीं था टील काम कैसे करता है या
फिर लोग को लगता है टी सिर्फ मतलब एसएल ही
है एग्जैक्ट और एचटीपीएस पे ही काम कर रहा
है बस सि ए प काम कर रहा है ऐसा चीजें
नहीं है ठीक है तो आपको समझना जरूरी है
बाकी आप इसके बारे में खुद भी पढ़ सकते
हैं और मैं तो बताऊंगा ही आपको तो दिक्कत
आपको इसम नहीं लेनी है एकदम भी और हम
चैलेंस भी करेंगे कुछ चलिए आज ही करेंगे
चैलेंज तो हम लोग नेक्स्ट वाला तो आज ही
करने वाले हैं हम चलिए इसको खत्म करते हैं
यहां पर ठीक है यहां पर भी कुछ खास नहीं
दिया हुआ है वही चीजें हैं कि आपके जो भी
सर्विसेस होती है जैसे एस एच एफटीपी सब
मैंने आपको बता था मिसकंफीग्रेशन बड़ी
दिक्कत हो सकती है मिस कॉन्फिन पे ही
बेस्ड है अगर उसके पासवर्ड बट फोर्स हो पा
रहे या फिर यूजरनेम हो पा रहा है तो सब
आपके मिसक फिगरेशन या फिर आपके इन चीजों
में दिक्कत में आ जाएगा ठीक है ना तो आपको
दिक्कत दे सकता है तो इन सब के जो
प्रोटोकॉल्स है ये सब बट फोर्स हो जाते
हैं इजली वो टलेट हो गया ए हो गया एफटीपी
हो गया ये सब इजली ब्लूट फोर्स हो जाते
हैं ठीक है तो आपको दिक्कत दे सकते हैं अब
बूट फोर्स के बहुत सार कैटेगरी होते हैं
जैसे पासवर्ड गेसिंग मतलब आपना नेम मोबाइल
नंबर ऐसा कुछ पासवर्ड रखा है तो गैस हो
जाएगा डायरेक्टली ठीक है डिक्शनरी टैग
बहुत सारे कॉमनली जो नोन वर्ड्स होते हैं
उनका इस्तेमाल करके एक वर्ड लिस्ट से ठीक
है ट फोर्स अटैक सारे कॉमिनेशन ट्राई करना
मतलब जैसे लेट्स से आपका पासवर्ड या फिर
आपका ओटीपी है ओटीपी आपका चार डिजिट का है
ठीक है तो 00 से लेके 999 तक सारे
कॉमिनेशन ट्राई कर लो इनमें से कोई एक तो
होगा ही ठीक है ब फोस का सक्सेस रेट तो
100% है ठीक है लेकिन डिपेंड करता है कि
कब तक होगा जन्म भी लेख सकते हैं कितने
ठीक है वो दिक्कत होती है चलिए एक बहुत ही
फेमस फाइल होती है रक टीटी जो हमने ू आउट
द अपना चैलेंज सब में यूज़ की है ऑलरेडी
तो पता होगा रटी एकटी आप सेक लिस्ट में भी
ले सकते हैं वहां मिल जाएगा आपको ये चीज
चलिए अब हाइड्रा का जो सिंटेक्स है व ये
है इस टाइप का है हाइड्रा हान l ठीक यूजर
नेम हान कैपिटल प वर्ड लिस्ट सर्वर और
सर्विस ठीक है अब दो चीज ध्यान रखने की
क्या है अगर आप यहां पर l या फिर p को
स्मॉल में लिखते हैं ठीक है तो आप यहां पर
यूज़र नेम या पासवर्ड सिंगल दे सकते हैं
और अगर आप इसको कैपिटल में लिखते हैं तो
आप वहां पर लिस्ट दे सकते हैं कहने का
मतलब क्या अगर आपको यूज़र नेम नहीं पता तो
आप एल को स्मॉल मत लिखो एल को कैपिटल लिखो
और यूज़र नेम जहां लिखा हुआ है यहां पे
यूज़र नेम की फाइल दो जिसमें सरा यूज़र
नेम हो और पासवर्ड का पता है ठीक है तो p
को स्मॉल लिखो और पासवर्ड यहां पे
डायरेक्टली दे दो ठीक है उसी पासवर्ड लिए
ट्राई करेगा और अगर आपको दोनों नहीं पता
दोनों कैपिटल लिखो ठीक है इस तरीके से समझ
रहे हैं ना आप मतलब स्मॉल लेटर सिर्फ एक
चीज को टिफाई करता है अगर स्मॉल पी है
मतलब एक पासवर्ड ठीक है पासवर्ड
डायरेक्टली दे रहे हैं अग पासवर्ड लिस्ट
है पूरी तो कैपिटल पी चलिए यूजर नेम भी
लगता है पासवर्ड में भी लगता है सर्वर
क्या है कहां पे आपको टैक करना है ठीक है
होस्ट नेम आईपी एड्रेस कुछ भी है सर्विस
कौन सा सर्विस है एएच है एफटीपी है क्या
टैक करना है एग्जांपल यहां पे दिया हुआ है
कुछ देख हाइड्रा हाफ एल मार्क मतलब स्मल
एल है मतलब मार्क यूजर नेम ही है ठीक है प
कैपिटल मतलब फाइल देखेंगे पासवर्ड के लिए
ये पासवर्ड फाइल हो गई रटी आई एड्रेस दे
दिया कहां पे टाइक करना है एफटीपी लिख
दिया ठीक है एफटीपी स पर टैक करना है चलिए
समझ में आ गया होगा आपको ये कैसे काम कर
रहा
है ए भी हो सकते हैं पोर्ट करने के लिए
अगर डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट नहीं यूज हो रहा मतलब
अगर एफटीपी डिफॉल्ट पोट यूज नहीं कर रहा
एस डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट यूज नहीं कर रहा कुछ
कस्टम पोर्ट यूज कर रहा तो आप हास लगा के
दे सकते हैं नवी लगा के आप वर्ब दे सकते
हैं कि आपको आट डिटेल में चाहिए ठीक है
हाटी लगा के आप यहां पर नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड दे
सकते हैं ठीक है चलिए डी लगा डी ब दे सकते
हैं इस को जरूरत होगी नहीं कंट्रोल c से
रोक भी सकते हैं वही चीज दी हुई है कुछ
नया नहीं है इसके मिटिगेशन क्याक है
मिटिगेशन यही सब भाई पासवर्ड पॉलिसी अच्छी
रखो ठीक है मिनिमम कंपलेक्सिटी मतलब आप
मिनिमम चार डिजिट कैपिटल ये सब यूज कर
अकाउंट लॉक आउट रखो इतनेट के बाद इने लग
बा ल लक हो जाएगा कैप्चर रखो ये तो कुछ
एटी एग्जांपल हो गया ये बाकी जगह भी लगता
है ठीक है ना कक आपको रोकना है किस तरीके
से वो भी एक आपके लिए मेजर इशू हो सकता है
तो व भी रोकना है चलिए वी लर्न ट वन ऑफ द
ईमेल अकाउंट इ लेजी क्या कोई क्वेन र
से तो कर लिया है हमने ट द पासवर्ड यूज टू
एक्सेस द आफ सर्विस ऑन इतना ठीक है टक
करना है और हमारा यूजर नेम है व
लेजी चलिए आई एडस पले कॉपी कर लेते हैं या
अटक करना शुरू करते य पर हम य पर ओपन कर
लेंगे हाइड्रा को अपने ठीक है हाइड्रा हम
यूजर नेम पता हुआ है हरा ऑलरेडी ठीक
हैलिए य हमारा यह रहा है ठीक है फ पासवर्ड
पास पा फाइल देने वाले हैं हमारी कहां पर
यूजर
शेयर वर्डलिस्ट
टी य फाइल देने वाले हैं आई एडस दे दिया
या हमने होस्ट सवर दे दिया अपना अब हमें
आई मैप पर अटैक करना है ठीक है चलिए एंटर
करते
हैंटक शुरू हो गया होगा
चलिए वेट करना है कुछ देर तक य
पर ये कक होता है वेट करते य पर समरी देख
लेते हैं समरी वही है इ सबका एक ट शीट
दिया हुआ है आपके लिए ठीक है उसका आपका
वाला अल्टरनेटिव क्या है य पर हाड ट दिया
हमने रेडी किया हुआ है इस रूम की काफी ची
हमने रेडी की हुई थी ठीक है ना बहुत कुछ
इस रूम में करने के लिए था नहीं लेकिन
आपको समझना जरूरी था ये चीज कि काम कैसे
कर रही है और आप कुछ नए टर्म भी आपको
जानने में मिले और ये सब आपको कनेक्ट करने
मिला सब कनेक्ट कैसे हो रहा है पासवर्ड आ
गया य पर बटरफ्लाई ठीक है सिंपल कॉपी करते
हैं इसको और यहां पर खत्म करते हैं पेस्ट
करके चलिए सबमिट यरू हमारा जो है कंप्लीट
होता है इसको आप शेयर कर दीजिए अगर आप साथ
में है तो नहीं है तो कोई बात नहीं है ठीक
है अगर आप इसको साथ में सॉल्व नहीं कर रहे
तो कोई बात नहीं अगर आप पेड रूम नहीं है
पेड अकाउंट नहीं है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
लेकिन आप जो भी वर्क कर रहे हैं साथ में
जो सीख रहे न बना रहे उसको शेयर कीजिए और
अभी ये लेक्चर खत्म नहीं हुआ है अब आता है
इस लेक्चर का कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग पार्ट टोटल
चैलेंज नेट सेक चैलेंज ठीक है यहां पर हम
क्या करने वाले हैं यहां पर हमने जो किया
है अभी तक मतलब इस पूरे मॉड्यूल में जो
सीखा है वो सब कुछ हम यहां पर अप्लाई
करेंगे डिफिकल्टी इसकी मीडियम दी गई है
ओके ठीक है देखते हैं मुझे ल इजी होगा पर
मीडियम दिया हुआ है देखते हैं क्या निकलने
वाला है और मैंने भी सॉल्व नहीं किया है
आपके सामने मैं सॉल्व कर रहा हूं ठीक है
तो कोई चिंता नहीं लेनी है अपने हिसाब से
सोचना है मैं भी अपने हिब से सोचने की
कोशिश करूंगा और आप सोचिए यहां पर क्या है
ठीक है देखते हैं य चैलेंज क्या है इसको
ओपन कर लेते हैं चलिए इसमें स्टार्ट कर
देते हैं पहले स्टार्ट भी हो रहा
है ओके यहां पर लिखा हुआ है कि आपका सिर्फ
यहां पर एन मैप नेट और हाइड्रा का
इस्तेमाल होने वाला है ठीक है मतलब
एन्यूमरेशन प ही है सब कुछ और रूट फोस प
इही दो चीजों पे आपका पूरा रूम टिकने वाला
है ठीक है चलिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आप
अपने ट्राई कीजिए ऐसा कुछ तो है नहीं
एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है कि से हो जाएगा
परेशान नहीं होना है ओके ठीक है यहां पर
काफी कुछ दिया हुआ है ऑलरेडी करने के लिए
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है इस करना है हो जाएगी
सबसे पहले यहां पर पोर्ट के बारे में
क्वेश्चन दिया हुआ है पहला काम हम यही
करेंगे कि इसके आईपी एड्रेस को आते ही जो
है कंप्लीट पोर्ट चालू कर देंगे ठीक है
व्ट द हाईएस्ट पोर्ट नंबर बीइंग ओपन लेसन
नंबर
00 ठीक है पहला क्वेश्चन हमारा य होने
वाला है जब तक ये ऑन हो रहा है आपको फिर
से ब बोल देता हूं कि हमारे लिन पेज को
फॉलो कर लीजिए और हमारे ए को जरूर डाउनलोड
कर लीजिए उसमें जितने भी नए कोर्स आते हैं
आपको मिल जाएंगे जल्दी कुछ नए कोर्स भी
आने वाले हैं उन डिस्काउंट भी अच्छा होगा
ठीक है और यकीन मानिए डिस्काउंट आपको जो
मिलेगा बेस्ट वो एप्लीकेशन मिलेगा और आपको
नोटिफिकेशन भी एप्लीकेशन प ही मिलेंगे तो
एप्लीकेशन तोस गलती मत कीजिएगा ठीक है
एप्लीकेशन को डउनलोड जरूर कर लीजिएगा प्
स्टोर आपको मिल जाएगा चलिए इसको मैं यहां
पर कॉपी करता हूं आड हमारा आ चुका है यहां
पर सिंपल सा एक एप का कंप्लीट पोर्ट स्कैन
चालू कर देते हैं ठीक है इसको पेस्ट कर
देता हूं यहां पर मैं यहां पर वर्ब दे
देते हैं हमरा जो कंप्लीट पोर्ट स्कन है
वो चालू हो चुका है
पहला क्वेश्चन यही था कि 10000 के अंदर
वाले पोर्ट को बताना है सॉरी ये गलती हो
गई ने कंप्लीट पो नहीं किया मैं बोल रहा
था लेकिन मैंने लगाया नहीं ए प लगा देता
हूं यहां पर ताकि जो है कंप्लीट पट स्कन
हो देखते हैं 10000 के अंदर अंदर सबसे
बड़े नंबर का कौन सा पोर्ट चालू
है
फिलहाल यहां पर दिक्कत दे रहा है मेरे
ख्याल से हम लोग इसको दूसरी टेक्निक से
ट्राई कर सकते
हैं मैं सिंपल सा एक कनेक्ट न करता हूं
फिर देखता हूं कितना आता
है चलिए
1021 नहीं ये हास्ट नहीं 139 हास्ट होना
चाहिए मेरे खल से फिर तो नहीं एक दोती च
चार वाला है 10000 पूछा यार ये 10 तो है
लाउ नहीं होना चाहिए और तो कोई पोर्ट इसने
स्कैन किया नहीं हाईएस्ट 139 ही पड़ रहा
है मेरे खल से तो क्वेश्चन है व्ट इ द
हाईएस्ट पोर्ट नंबर बीइंग ओपन लेसन 10
10000 से नीचे और यहां पर यह 1021 है ये
नीचे तो है नहीं और जो हास्ट है व 445 है
न य पर आंसर जो है वह एक दो तीन चार डिजिट
में है देखना
पड़ेगा ट देखते हैं यहां पर
21 ही
है एक्सेप्ट नहीं
होगा पर मे भी कोई पोर्ट मिस हुआ
है तो कंप्लीट हो चुका है य परने फाइंड
नहीं किया चलिए आगे देखते हैं ओपन पोट
आउटसाइड द कॉमन पोर्ट इट इ अब 10000 व्ट इ
इट य पर दिया हुआ है इसके लिए य आंसर होगा
चलिए हानी ी पोर्ट्स आर ओपन कितने ओपन है
य पर एक दो तीन च पा यहां पर है और एक जो
यहां पर आने वाला है डिटेक्ट नहीं हो पा
रहा है तो छह ट्राई करते हैं सही आंसर है
मतलब एक कोई जो है पोर्ट वो और है जो कि
यहां पर डिटेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है कि कौन सा
है भाई कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हम देखेंगे
नहीं तो उसको दूसरे तरीके से स्कैन कर
देंगे लास्ट में चलिए व्हाट इज द हिडन
फ्लैग हिडन इन द एटीटीपी सर्वर हेडर
एटीटीपी च यहां पर स्कैन होने का वेट करते
हैं
कंप्लीट देखते हैं जब यहां पर स्कैन
कंप्लीट होती है तो क्या निकल के आता है
60 पर हो चुका है अभी
से होगा सवर तो डली ओपन कर लेते हैं देखते
हैं हमें सर्वर चाहिए डर चाहिए तो पर नेट
ट्राई कर लेते हैं सिंपल टट से क्या करने
वाले हैं य पर आ कॉपी करते हैं पेस्ट करते
हैं य पर ट्राई करते हैं प कनेक्ट करने का
देखते क्या य मिल जाती
है गेट कर देते हैं सिंपल
सा गट कर देते
है यहा परने आ गया है रा फ्लग है टी एचएम
वेब सर्वर वाला ये हमें मिल गया हमारा
फ्लैग इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं और यहां पर
पेस्ट कर देते हैं च ये हमारा हो गया व्ट
इ द फ्लैग इन द एस सर्वर हेडर एस में क्या
है भाई एस में क्या है ए देख लेते हैं
सिंपल एस में कनेक्ट कर लेते हैं या फि
डायरेक्टली य से कर लेते हैं इसको भी
टेलनेट ट्राई करते हैं टेलनेट
से नेट ट्राई कर लेते हैं या
चलो 21 लिखते हैं यहां पर देखते हैं क्या
आता है एक मिनट यहां पर स्कन कंप्लीट है य
दे चुका होगा हमको रेडी
ुद दे दिया होगा य देखिए मिल गया इस लिख
होगा इसने हमारे लिएट कर दिया
ऑलरेडी यह इसने सिंपल बैनर ग्रबिंग किया
और कुछ नहीं किया है ओपन कर लेता हूं कहां
गया कनेक्ट करते य पर तो आपको मिल जाएगा य
देखि मिल गया ठीक सेम ही है इसको पेस्ट कर
देते हैं यहां पर और हमारा एडर फ्लग हो
गया वी हैव एफटीपी सवर लिनिंग नन स्टंड
पोर्ट न टी सर्वर एक नॉन स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट
पर एफटीपी चल रहा है ये कौन से प चल रहा
है भाई एफटीपी और करते हैं
इसको करते हैं एफटीपी हमारा यहां पर चल
रहा है 1021 प चल रहा है यह हमारा एफटीपी
का वर्जन है सिंपल कॉपी करते हैं
इसको यहां पर इसको पेश कर देते हैं चलिए
वी लर्न टू यूजर नेम यूजिंग सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग ठीक है हमें दो यूजरनेम मालूम
चल गए हैं कैसे मालूम चले हमें मतलब नहीं
है व्ट इज द फ्लैग हिडन इन वन ऑफ दिस टू
अकाउंट फाइल्स एंड एक्सेसिबल एफटीपी ठीक
है दो यूजर नेम है और एफटीपी का पासवर्ड
में एफटीपी नहीं पता है और एफटीपी के थ्र
एक्सेस करना है तो हम इसको ट फोर्स करने
का ट्राई कर सकते
हैं यहां पर क्या करने वाले हैं हम यहां
पर सिंपल सा एक जो है फाइल बनाएंगे यूजर
नाम से ठीक है जिसमें हम दोनों यूजर नेम
डाल देंगे हमारा क्या है एडी और क्विन एडी
और क यू आई एन एन था
शायद ओके ठीक है एडी
और इसको हम लोग यहां पर सेव कर देंगे ठीक
है र नाम से हमने सेव कर दिया अब हम कैट
करेंगे अगर कैट यूजर इसमें दोन यूजर का
नेम है हम लिखेंगे हाइड्रा ठीक है एल
कैपिटल बिकॉज हम यूजर नेम की लिस्ट देने
वाले हैं भी कैपिटल बिकॉज हम पासवर्ड की
जो है लिस्ट देने वाले हैं यूजर शेयर
लि ठीक है फिर हम क्या देना है आई एडस
देना है कहां पर हमें करना है य हमारा
आईपी एड्रेस हो गया फ क्या देंगे देने ले
क करना एंटर करते इसको ठीक
है नहीं हो रहा तो नन रन हो रहा है 1021 प
सही है इस बार ओके एफटीपी हमने नहीं लिखा
सर्विस कौन सी है ठीक है सर्विस लिखेंगे उ
ख दिया मैंने एटीपी लिखेंगे सर्विस और पोट
देंगे आ ए से ठीक है 1021 प करना है एटर
करते हैं य पर अटैक शुरू हो चुका है चलिए
एटीपी सर्विस पर अटैक करना है हमें और दो
यूजर नेम साथ करना है दोनों में से जो भी
यूर नेम लग जाएगा य उस वर्क कर देगा ठीक
है देखिए एडी लग गया
जॉर्डन जन य मिल चुका है य पर देखते हैं
क्वेश्चन क्या था कि एक्सेस करना था या
फिर फाइल देना था कोई ठीक है
एडी के साथ जर्डन दोनों मिल गया एडी के
साथ जॉर्डन ट्राई करते हैं पहले ठीक इसको
क्लोज कर देते हैं अभी के लिए इसको बंद
करते हैं अभी के लिए क्लोज नहीं
करेंगे चलिए भैया इसको कॉपी करते हैं यहां
पर करते एटीपी ठीक है एडी रेट
ये ओके सॉरी यहां पर डायरेक्टली करते हैं
य उतर तो पूछ ही
लेगा स्टंड पोर्ट भी है हमारा देते को स्
देना है च आ गया
एडी
जर्डन एस करते
हैं एलस
ए ठीक य कोई फाइल नहीं हैट करते हैं चलिए
अब दोबारा करने वाले इस लॉगइन ठीक है इस
बार इस बार हमारा क्रेडेंशियल क्या रहने
वाला हैन और
एंड्रिया क्या रने वाला
हैन
और
एंड्रिया गन हो गया लेस करते यहां पर फाइल
मिल गई है गेट कर देते हैं एटीपी
अंडर फग डटी नड कर लिया हमने एट कर देते
हैं य से कट करते हैं एफटीपी फ्लैग हम
फ्लैग जो है हमारा मिल चुका है इसको करते
हैं कॉपी यहां
से उस देते यहां पर पेस्ट एक काम मुझे और
कर देना चाहि था पहले ही जो मैं दोबारा
करने वाला हूं अभी यहां
पर क्लोज कर देते हैं अभी के लिए इसको भी
यहां पर क्लोज कर देते हैं इसका भी काम हो
चुका है जो पहला क्वे था उसके लिए हम लोग
यहां पर एन्यूमरेशन चालू रखेंगे इसको मैं
क्लियर करता हूं कंपलीटली और मैंने जो
कमांड रन की थी यह वाली इस पर मैं आता हूं
वापस से कोट को मैं दे देता हूं यहां पर
जीरो से 10 000 तक के लिए ठीक है कक इसके
अंदर चाहिए हमें और यहां पर इसको हटा देते
हैं इवन इसको भी हटा देते हैं कोई मतलब
नहीं है ये भी करने का अभी ठीक है सिंपल
सा रन करना चालू कर देते हैं इसको इसको
बैकग्राउंड में होने देते हैं देख लिया
जाएगा ठीक है 8080 आ गया 8080 ये यहां पे
चल रहा था
चलिए ये चीज को दर्शाता है कैसे आपको
मल्टीपल तरीके से पोर्ट स्कैन करना पड़
सकता है ता आपको सही रिजल्ट ना मिले
एजेक्ट रिजल्ट ना मिले कुछ पोर्ट मिस हो
जाए ठीक है तो न तरीके से आप कर सकते हैं
चलिए ये देखिए यहां पर लास्ट में दिया ही
हुआ था कोई जरूरत नहीं थी करने की यह तो
बाहरी मिस्टेक हो गया कोई बात नहीं
चलिए इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां
पर वेट करते हैं इसके ओपन होने
का
चलिए क् डिस्पले स्मल चैलेंज ट ल य फ्लग
सल्ट ठीक है हम च फॉल करना है र मिशन ट य
स्न नास
मशीन कवर्टली एस पॉसिबल एंड अवॉइड बीइंग
डिटेक्टेड बाय आईडीएस ठीक है हमें आईडीएस
से यहां पर डिटेक्ट नहीं होना है ये एक
चैलेंज है ये बढ़िया है यार पूरे उसमें
चैलेंज नहीं था लास्ट चैलेंज आ गया सही है
भाई चलिए कॉपी करते हैं
इसको पैकेट अकाउंट ठीक है ये ओपन रखना है
मेरे ख्याल से और यहां पर क्या करना है
ओके ओपन र करते
पहले क्या करना है इसको हमें स्कैन करना
है तो मैं य पर ए ओपन करता
हूं ठीक है चलिए
य पर हम क्या करने वाले ए का य पर हेल्प
देखने वाले हैं ठीक
है देखते है यहां पर हमने काफी तरीके देखे
थे ऑलरेडी जिस कर सकते हैं फिर देखते हैं
य हमारा बेस्ट कौन सा हो सकता है य मि हो
गया आउटपुट हो गया नहीं है देखते हैं
हमारा कौन सा बेस्ट तरीका काम करेगा य पर
आ गया ट
फायरवॉल ये देखिए ये आपका सेक्शन है यहां
पर फायरवॉल आइडिया इवेशन एफ ठीक है ये
आपका पूरा सेक्शन है पर आप सोर्स एड्रेस
प्रूफ कर सकते हैं या
आपका वाला बताया था ठीक है कर सकते देखते
य पर बेस्ट हमारा कौन सा चल सकता है अभी
के लिए मेरे खल से हम य पर फ्रेगमेंटेशन
दे सकते
हैं
तो दे सकते हैं वसे
तो ट्राई करते एक बार
हम चलिए देते ट्राई करते हैं य
पर कर दिया हमने य
पर जरत नहीं है कर दो सिंपल और वर्ग बस
में आउटपुट दे दो चलिए देखते हैं क्या
होता है यहां
पर इसको स्मल में रन करने देते
हैं चांसेस ऑफ स्कैन बीइंग डिटेक्टेड 100%
लिखा हुआ है सही
है
% क्या
चलिए रहा है ओपन करते हैं अपना वापस से
सॉरी देखते स्कन का क्या हो रहा
है स्कन रन नहीं हो रही
है वेट करते हैं कंपलीट होने तक
का चलिए तो यह काफी ज टाइम ले रहा है
दूसरा कुछ ट्राई करते हैं य पर ठीक है
इसको वेट करते
हैं स् करते देखते क्या हो रहा
है हमने इस रिफ्रेश करते हैं यहां
पर आंसर में क्या कोई फ्लग चा र को फग
चाहिए देखते हैं
इसको य
जीरो होहा हो जा रहा है पैकेट
काउंट करते देखते कितना हो रहा है
पर कुछ ट्रा करते हैं यहां पर कुछ
एक्स्ट्रा जो है यहां पर हम लोग डन करते
हैं
इसमें य पर मशीन लग कर रही है क्योंकि य
वेब बेस्ड मशीन
है य पर के प आते हैं तो हम पहले यहा पर
पिंग बंद कर सकते हैं अपना सबसे पहला काम
तो वो कर सकते हैं उस कर दिया जाएगा अभी
डिय अटैक है आई एडस पफिंग
है हम कर सकते य पर मेरे ख्याल से हमें
डियट पहले काम करते हैं सिंपल सा कमांड
आते है वापस से य पर अपनी जो है स्कैनिंग
सॉरी पि स्कन को बंद करते हैं ठीक है ए
हमने अपने पि स्कन को बंद कर दिया य पर
एंटर करते हैं स्कैनिंग चल रही है देते
हैं देखते क्या हो रहा
है
रि करने ट्राई करते हैं देखते हैं 9 पर
अभी भी आ रहा
है
पर
चलिए डालना शुरू करते हैं य
पर करते कंट्रोल सी
से एडी कर देते य पर हम कोई
रमते
डडडड
3.56
मी करते है इसको देखते हैं क्या होता है
यहां
पर 14 पर आ रहा है
ये इसको य पर रिफेच किया जाता
है मे भीय कलेट करने में टाइम लगा रहा है
जदा परसेंट तो बढ़ता जा रहा है नहीं चाहिए
वसे
परसेंट और ची ट्राई करते हैं मेरे खल से य
पर बढ़ते जा रहे है तो हम ने ट्राई करते
हैं अगर हम यहां पर मान लीजिए टक को हटाते
हैं ठीक है सिंपल सिर्फ एस रहने देते हैं
य पर कंप्लीट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग को भी हटा
देते हैं अभी के लिए ठीक है इसको भी हटा
देते
हैं पर य पर डिसेबल करके हम यहां पर ट्राई
करते हैं एंटर करने का देखते हैं अब क्या
हो रहा है यहां पर ठीक है सिंपल कुछ नहीं
था हमने क्या किया य पर पिं क्लक कर दिया
हमारे पास आई एड्रेस यहां पर आ गया चलिए
सॉरी फल जो पास पर आ गया कॉपी करते हैं
हालाकि मुझे उतना बढ़िया चैज लगा नहीं
क्योंकि मेरे ख्याल से और चीज थी जो ठीक
है वो
सस्पें रोक भी सकती है ठीक है उसे बचा भी
सकती है मेरे ख्याल से तो वो सही था कोई
नहीं चलिए जो भी
है पूरा ही कॉपी कर लेते हैं
यार ये कॉपी करने का सिस्टम नहीं है क्या
भाई सिलेक्ट नहीं हो रहा व कर देते हैं
इसको ये इमेज है
क्या इसको यहां
पर थोड़ा सिस्टम मेरा यहां पर लक कर रहा
है
क्योंकि सॉरी अपने स्पेक्ट पे आता हूं
वापस
से
चलिए कोई नहीं तो कर लीजिए कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है य पर कॉपी करना है जो है य भी
कंपलीट हो
जाएगा सबमिट कर लेते हैं इसको कर देता
यार तो कर देते हैं इसको
भी चलिए आ जाएगा
हमारा
का करते हैं ये टास्क का आंसर आ गया
था हो रहा है यहां पर चलिए कोई नहीं इसको
यहां पर सिंपल कंप्लीट सेलेक्ट करते हैं
इसको कॉपी कर देते हैं इनर एचटीएमएल कॉपी
कर लिया हमने यहां पर आ गया हम नोटपैड में
सिंपल य पर इसको यहां पर वेस्ट करते हैं
ये हमारा हमारे पास क्या आ गया फ्लैग आ
गया यहां पर कट कर लेते हैं सिंपल चलिए
यहां पर हम
इसको सबमिट करते हैं फाइनल और यह रूम भी
हमारा कंप्लीट हुआ ठीक है उम्मीद करता हूं
य आपको समझ में आ गया होगा नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी का जितना बेसिक मॉड्यूल जितना
चीज था वो हमने पूरा ए टू जेड कंप्लीट कर
लिया है ठीक है हमने ए टू जेड कंप्लीट कर
लिया है तो मुबारक को अगर आपने एंड तक
पूरा देखा है तो आगे भी रहेगी होता
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी अब कंटिन्यू ना हो हां
वो जो लेक्चर मैंने आपको कहा वो मैं आपको
अलग से दे दूंगा ठीक है र पॉसिबल हो पा पे
करा देंगे हम उसको भी प्रैक्टिकल वाला बट
वो ऐसा जिका कोई पार्ट नहीं है ठीक है मीन
इसका जितने भी चीज थी वो हमने कंप्लीट करा
ली है कुछ चैलेंस भी हम आपके लिए जल्दी ही
लाने वाले हैं और कुछ कोर्सेस भी लाने
वाले हैं तो हमारे चैनल प पे बंद रगा
लगातार ठीक है उसपे आपको जो है पक्का सेका
बनाके आपको एक्टिव रहना है ठीक है
एप्लीकेशन पे आपको जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन होग
नोटिफिकेशन के थ्रू आपको मिलती जाएगी और
भी फ्यूचर में आपके लिए और सीरीज लाऊंगा
ठीक है होप फुली ट्रामी की लाऊंगा आप
कमेंट जरूर कीजिएगा आपको ट्राक म की और
सीरीज चाहिए या नहीं चाहिए ठीक है अ दूसरी
चीज कुछ चाहिए मैं आपको उस हिसाब से आपको
चीजें आके आपको प्रोवाइड करूंगा ठीक है
चलिए तो आज के लेक्चर में इतना ही करते
हैं थैंक्स फॉर वाचिंग ने लेर में नेट
सिक्योरिटी के नहीं किसी िक के चलिए